the jurogan experience you know
here's another thing uh because it's
quite along the same line
because and i hope i don't get emotional
on this one but so
you know when i was uh 15 i'd won a
state championship
and uh uh
my first state championship in wrestling
first year as a high school sophomore
because that high school started then
and i uh
anyway long story short this neighbor
kid
ended up murdering my sister and uh
he had walked to school with me a couple
weeks before that
and said something to me who i sh
if i would have communicated
it might have saved her life you know
just because
she probably would have never let the
guy into the her house
what did he say he just said like boy
you got a
hot sister you know and he was kind of
my age one year older than me but my
sister was four years older than me so
he was probably
16 and she was 19. and and
she had a boyfriend and she was living
at home yet
and and uh so
so the funny thing is is
i didn't i actually was going to come
home and say something to her but when i
got home i got distracted and i said
it's just boy talk you know it's this
boy talking
it was mostly about he he just thought
my sister was really hot and that he
would like to
do something with her you know but he
never really said it outright i mean
i just figured something you know the
boy boys would like to do
you know but anyway so you know that
two weeks later we're on a fishing trip
with my mom and dad and my sister's
supposed to join us
and she doesn't show up because she
works for my dad
after uh she went to college for a year
and then she worked for my dad
uh after that as a secretary in the real
estate business
so uh she didn't show up
so we called the neighbor and back in
those days she didn't have cell phones
so we had a
we had a phone uh that was outside a
cabin that we rented
you know you know you know i can date
you because the date at the cabin we
rented for four bucks a night
so you know it's just unheard of and
that was you know would have you know
been uh
1964. so so we were at a pay phone about
a half a block
from from the cabin that we were renting
and we rolled the window down and you
put the
dime dimer nickel in the phone and you
call my dad called the uh
i was in the front back seat my mom and
dad were in the front my dad was driving
and he called the neighbor and asked if
um
my sister's car was still in the
driveway and he said yes
so and she was supposed to be with us 90
miles away that morning
and she didn't show up so
so my dad and my mom get really nervous
and i tell they tell them to go get
break into that house if you you know if
there's nobody you know you can't get in
break into it or she doesn't answer the
door but you know get into that house
and call us back
so it's you can see the tension in the
front seat of the car
you know i can see my mom and dad
worrying the phone rings finally at
about 15 minutes later
and all of a sudden the uh
my dad drops the phone and
and my my mom was going she was kind of
going starting to
go hysterical know what was wrong and
and
he looked over and i'll never forget
this you know being a 15 year old kid
and i looked at my dad said to her
diane's not alive and oh my god
you know it's just my mom opened the
door of the car
she took off running back to the block
to the cabin
i got out and ran after him when i when
i followed her into the cabin by that
time she was already on the floor
and she had grabbed her hair and she was
pulling her head
hitting the wooden floor and she looked
up and she had blood all over
her forehead and
so my dad then followed in and we packed
up real quick
like what 10 minutes we left half the
stuff then we took off from my hometown
about 90 miles away but within 15 min
within a half hour of that phone call
i was in the back seat and there was a
lot of trauma going on in that front
seat
and i said to my dad
dad i may know something about this
i don't know for sure but i may and you
know
he overreacted he slammed the car the
brakes on the car
got out of the car came around opened
the door pulled me out slammed me
against the door
what do you mean you may know something
about it and then i told him the story
about
the two weeks before that me walking to
school with a neighbor kid
and that what he had said and he just
hugged me and threw me back in the car
and we stopped at the next town which is
about 15 miles later and went into the
police station
and we told the police what had happened
as far as
uh sister daughter getting
murdered the night before and we were on
our way there but
but this my kid told me a story and i
think if you could help me
as soon as possible so they called ahead
to the waterloo police department the
waterloo police
located he was at work
sacking groceries the next day in a
grocery store
and so they and he'd actually admitted
right there that he did it
you know after they they they got him
but the thing is
what's amazing is
this guy and then he escaped from prison
after about 20
he was only 16 he went got life in
penitentiary
you know and uh and uh he escaped and
that pretty much doomed him ever getting
out
and uh then because he was out for a
month before they they caught him and he
actually
in the trial he was so mad about getting
sentenced to life in prison that he
pointed to the gable family
and on the way out and he said he was
going to kill us all
and so anyway this guy goes to prison
and he lives and
he dies in prison after he broke out he
never really got a chance to ever let
him out
but here's the thing so it's just about
i don't know say it seven eight years
ago when he passed away
but we got another cabin now it's about
30 miles north of the cabin that
was we were in that time and that was a
rental cabin that's torn down now
and we go right by that place
so we're going right by that place
actually i'd been
me and my wife had been at our cabin
that my mom and dad
owned and they i inherited when they
passed on but we were at that kansas
uh cabin and we were coming home and we
were going right by the spot
where that pay phone was and where
we had learned about her death and
there's a cell phone call it's the
warden
of the prison he's in i think it was
um indiana he was in indiana the prison
and the warden told me
that the guy that murdered your sister
just died the exact same spot where i
learned
of the murder i was driving by and it's
130
it's about 115 miles from wells actually
a lot further than that
so it's like spooky it's like real
spooky and then what what's really
amazing
is what he said to me the warden
he said before he died
he was seeing a counselor and the
counselor told me this
that he said you know i really he
repented
he said i really shouldn't have i feel
bad about killing
diane gable i mean this is years later
but that he had told and he had been
rehabbed somewhat
and he goes and the reason why
he said i knew i was going to kill
somebody but he said because she was
such
a nice girl
you know oh my god he said he knew he
was going to kill somebody he said he
knew he was going to kill somebody
just it was just who he was yeah and
they told me that and
and you know i cried for an hour
and it got a lot out of me but
you know as bad as my dad
felt my mom felt and you know i felt
probably
it kind of got rid of a lot of hatred
when they when he told me that that he
admitted that she was such a nice girl
that he shouldn't have done it
and it was you know probably not too
full for he probably did it on his
deathbed or something but he probably
had all this guilt but
but you know it helped me too and it
helped me because even though i
i cried for an hour and i i think
that stuff you build up inside you
sometimes you just
you don't know what it's going to take
to get it get it out of you and i think
that really helped
me with my situation because you always
feel a little guilty because
of maybe you could have saved your life
but but more than that
it's been something that i based my
whole life on too
just communication i mean this is your
business
communication i mean there's and
sometimes my wife
tells me i'm telling her too much you
know you don't need to tell me
you know we don't need to talk about
this i said yeah i do i do
you know i need to talk about it's not
just that it's just anything that
there's crops up
i need to go home and i need to have a
conversation
with somebody that i that i
i like and love and um to be able to
see whether i'm doing the right thing or
i'm not doing the right thing
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience